it is time to get cooking with nanny
bubby thanks to chapman automotive who
is sponsoring this segment of course
today she's showing us how to make a
delicious taco charcuterie board and of
course this is something going viral and
all social media and the internet and i
have never seen it done so i'm excited
oh my god and i am actually looking
forward to you kind of calling it out
and helping me out i'd love to the idea
actually
good this idea actually came to me by
one of the members of nanny bubby's
facebook group which is gather with
nanny bubby she actually became a member
rocky after watching you and me and then
she googled it and founded her facebook
big search and i thought it was
i know i know and i thought it was so
cute but the word taco charcuterie just
didn't go because i think of a
charcuterie board as being meats and
cheese and french and italian and rice
and that's what's bible right now
yes and the word char charcuterie shar
means meat and kut means cooked so any
meat that is cooked makes a charcuterie
board so before we assemble it together
i just want to bring you over here i
want to show you one little recipe hack
for mexican street corn and then we'll
just get over here and put it all
together so
this is an ear of corn and i started it
already but in order to get all the silk
off and get it out of the husk
this is what you do you put it in the
microwave completely sealed not cut for
four minutes
when it's done still hot and steaming
which this one is you cut off the stem
and then you just literally start
squeezing and as you squeeze it comes
right out no silk at all how do you like
that you got all the then the next thing
you do is put it
yeah all the moves huh you should see me
dance and then here we go you put it in
a bundt can with the narrow piece and
just cut down the bundt pan catches all
that fabulous corner doesn't go
everywhere just turn and keep cutting
and that is the hack this goes into
a saute pan with red peppers green
peppers green onions and garlic and it
is the star of the show so we're going
to put it in the dish in your prettiest
dish
which is in the center all the way on
you're already on your board put that
corn right in
we'll put a little spoon in there for
those that want it and we're going to
start to assemble so here's the one
thing rocky those things that are going
to be on your board meaning that they're
not in little cups and plates like i
have them here those things you put on
first and now you assemble everything
else around it so to you my friend what
do you like on your tacos oh okay
obviously
meat
is there meat okay what options do we
have
how about
so we have chicken smoked chicken we
have the beef right and then right here
we have
okay with chicken and shrimp so we'll
put those right here so what you want to
do is put your meats into one area okay
and then we're going to our how about
our guacamole you like guacamole that is
my favorite yes yes load it on load it
off okay there's tomato guacamole and
then the
okay here we got the tomatoes from the
pico de gallo right over here right
black beans cheese right here my friend
how about that how good does that look
can't do it and how about just kind of
squeeze it all in no how about a little
bit of lettuce for you oh absolutely
right yeah there we go and
cilantro right notice this is an anaheim
pepper already cut and swirled just like
that with the cilantro right there and
then set some limes just kind of tuck
those limes right in i have a line here
a little bit later for that to keep that
tequila that we're gonna you know
yeah there you go there you go and how
about red onion are you liking that you
know okay i'm gonna say my bedroom
but you go ahead and do it
okay all right
oh no i can't do it believe me i'd be up
for three nights okay how about some
queso cheese of course that makes it
absolutely fabulous
and a little bit of sour cream which
will take the heat off perfect of the
jalapenos and the red and green peppers
and look how beautiful and colorful this
is there we have it i have about 30
seconds left yep and of course
we have well we've got a lime
and a shot of tequila do i dare tequila
come on now
oh it's right here i'll do it for you
bubbe cheers
yeah
there you go
oh my god
do you know what it's actually it's
actually water but i thought it would
make great television so there you go
okay fine stay hydrated great weekend
thank you so much nanny bubby spread
love like buddy you can check out nanny
bubby's kitchen and garden on social
media and online at nannybubby.com thank
you to chapman automotive for sponsoring
this fun